احتفالا بالذكرى العاشره لظهورها 11 جمهور
فرقه بي تي اس الكوريه الجنوبيه لموسيقى
البوب من مختلف انحاء العالم في العاصمه
سيول هذا الاسبوع اضيئه معالم مثل سيول
سيتي
باللون الارجواني اللون المميز لهذه
الفرقه الف
رقه هيرفنيه موسيقيه فريده اكتسحت العالم
بقوه خلال السنوات الماضيه مؤلفه من سبعه
اعضاء وحققت نجاحا باهرا على مدى عشر
سنوات قسمت خلالها في نشر موسيقى البوب
الكوريه الجنوبيه بل ايضا حطمت العديد من
الارقام القياسيه العالميه العديد من
اعمال الفرقه تصدرت قوائم الاغاني الاكثر
نجاحا حاصله ايرادات بمليارات الدولارات
واجتذبت عددا هائلا من المتابعين في مختلف
انحاء العالم
وراحت عليك يا اشواك
معاهم
بعدين مشهورين جدا على فكره مش بس في
كوريا او في منطقه مثلا اسيا ولكن في كل
انحاء العالم وهذا بياكد لنا موضوع قديش
القوه الناعمه قادره على انها بالفعل يعني
توصل للناس في شتى لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والت الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات